today's topic the bella thorne versus
Whoopi Goldberg incident so what Nicki
you heard what I said there's a listen
that happen essentially her nudes
someone was trying to blackmail her and
she didn't want to pay so she ended up
leaking it herself
some people suspect it's for a book deal
that's coming up right now she's about
to release her book so this is promo
who knows we're not sure but anyways she
was on Instagram she's got really
tearful about the whole situation and
then Whoopi Goldberg released a video of
the bella thorne yes or named Bella who
I send out on pornhub
and it confused me because I'm like who
cares about ludes that we already seen
in action of love eh I'm not gonna care
about stills if I seen the live action
that so late if you're famous I don't
care how old you are you don't take nude
pictures of yourself in one person but
she said listen when they're hacking you
they're hacking all of your stuff so
whether it's one picture or a million
pictures once you take that picture it
goes into the cloud and it's available
to any hacker who wants it and if you
don't know that in 2019 but this is an
issue you're so [ __ ] happy because I
can only imagine all of the kids who
have their [ __ ] release and then they
commit suicide and you know you're so
crazy prefer for thinking such terrible
things on such an awful situation like I
don't think anybody here saying that
what's happened to you who's okay
alright everyone acknowledges that what
happened to you is wrong and that is
evil okay you can acknowledge that right
you being extorted you someone's
stealing your stuff everyone looks at
that as being wrong Wow nobody looks at
it otherwise so let's start there second
thing Whoopie he's not happy about how
she made you feel Whoopi's not happy
that you're crying okay there's a lesson
to be learned here instead of learning
it you're trying to really get
everyone's empathy towards you without
actually listening to what's going on
she's not trying to encourage what may
potentially lead to suicide for young
children what if she actually is doing
is trying to prevent it if you have a
medium that is unsafe and you place your
valuables in
medium and it gets stolen don't be
surprised it's unsafe unfortunately
there are evil people out there there is
no world you're ever gonna live in where
murders are not gonna exist you know you
can't teach your sons not to murder
can't teach your daughters not to murder
can't teach people not to lie you can't
teach people not to rape
sometimes people are just garbage human
beings okay that happens people do evil
[ __ ] and because we recognize that
people have a propensity to do good we
also have to acknowledge that sometimes
people can also do bad that's just the
way it is some people are broken some
people had a bad childhood we don't know
and because these people exist you
should do what you can as a decent
person to securitize your equipment your
valuables your price positions yourself
okay let's say I find out that there's a
bank nearby that is unsecured it's been
robbed four times everyone gets their
[ __ ] stolen there's no protection you
know what I wouldn't do I wouldn't put
my valuable possessions in that Bank why
because I understand that there's a
likelihood that it's gonna get robbed
and if you look at your phone phones
have been getting hacked for the last 20
years okay
they've been getting their [ __ ] stolen
all the time it's been happening it
hasn't stopped you've heard this story
over and over so people have clued in
and be like hey phones are unsafe you
cannot guarantee that what I put in my
phone is gonna stay in my phone and so
if I understand that maybe it's more
safe for me to not put my nudes there
why cuz people can use that against me I
would put my social insurance number in
there I wouldn't put my banking info in
there I wouldn't put a lot of [ __ ] in
there and if I'm putting another message
to young girls it's to stop them from
making that mistake Briana said in 2009
she had leaked photo she said therefore
my boyfriend at the time you don't send
your boyfriend naked pictures then I
feel bad for him maybe I'm in a minority
but I really don't like receiving news
pictures don't do anything for me [ __ ]
shots especially are some of the most
nasty things I've ever seen personally I
just pictures don't do [ __ ] for me but I
jerk off to videos you know like I was
dating a girl who wanted to send me news
and I was like but I'm like I'm good
they say what's wrong with you nothing
I'm [ __ ] you later tonight
like why my [ __ ] youth for the night
I don't need to see your nudes I'm
[ __ ] you later and if I'm not then I
don't want to see what I'm not gonna get
I want to get no pictures of no food I'm
knockin wheat I don't want to see no
[ __ ] pictures with no car never gonna
drive I don't see no pictures of no
money I'm never gonna get don't be
sending me no cheques picture I don't
want to see that [ __ ] again if you're
not gonna give me that check and if I'm
gonna check you just give me a check I
don't know picture just give me the
goods
good good I don't want to see proof of
the dude I saw the picture of her news
whatever I have to be honest about if I
had that body I'd post them at the Food
Emporium
I don't really want to go on the view
anymore because I told me they want to
be beaten down by a bunch of older women
for my body and my sexuality ha again
they said if he had a body like you they
will put it off because if you got a
good body [ __ ] that's a compliment I've
seen that before I've seen why women
who've said something racist you like
hey that's racist and they start bawling
their eyes you know I think it is I
think white women have very Savior
complex they think yourself as both the
victim of patriarchy and the people to
stop it and save the world yes and so
they can't imagine a world in which
they're actually the ones who are in the
wrong so whenever they're in the wrong
what do they do they go straight to cry
so that they can go and regain their
victim status and no longer be seen as
somebody who's in the wrong and I'm just
thinking it's crazy when she originally
came out with her porn post she felt
like a hero right she said I'm her
posting his news myself I'm such a hero
bla bla bla I'm not saying what she do
is inherently wrong but that's what she
thought and the moment she got any
criticism it was straight to crying and
I'm just like oh can you kick can we
stop you know what my sister doesn't do
she went to Greece and you know what my
girl my sister didn't do take pictures
with three kids she didn't do that I'm
gonna cancel my interview because
I don't really want you guys talking
about your views to young girls shame on
you
[Music]
and shame on you for putting that public
opinion just out there like that that's
what we call it public bathroom that
will we call it a public opinion because
so you get to put your public opinion
out there but some of the disagrees you
doesn't you are the definition of a
snowflake saying if you take a sexy
photo then it basically deserves to get
leaked like don't be surprised at all
and don't feel sorry for yourself so if
I go out to a party drinking and I want
to dance on the dance floor do I deserve
to be raped too rough we're then oh
we're done we're good we're done we're
do you want to keep on born right great
oh I'll be back there oh I'm good oh you
made it out to seem like she condones
rape bro I'm over you
I think you're wack I think people who
believe what you believe are wack you
guys aren't capable of real discussion
this is crazy talk you know this is from
grand theft auto vice city yes oh yo
this my city put me on some of the best
ride ever yes I would steal a car in
Vice City and if the [ __ ] put on a good
radio station I wouldn't kill him when I
robbed his car
great music anyways oh that's a great
note to end Rock tell us what you guys
think in the comments below leave your
comments
[Music]